alors bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur arte france le temps
presse nous sommes à quelques mois de la
fin de la période de transition
peut-on espérer un compromis à la fin de
ces cinq semaines de négociations à
votre avis c'est toute la question mais
c'est vrai que ça fait déjà quatre ans
et demi qu on discute de ce break site
qui était à thèmes majeurs jusqu'à il ya
peu mais on vient de le voir avec le
président hama cran et la chancelière
merkel l'union européenne maintenant à
d'autres chats à fouetter et la grande
bretagne en grande partie aussi parce
que qui aurait pu prévoir il ya six mois
qui avait une telle catastrophe
économique comme le co vide qui rentrent
en jeu donc quelque chose qui était
vraiment très important pour les deux
parties dans cette négociation est
devenu un peu moins important maintenant
parce qu'il ya à faire face à ces
territoires du triste ans a mené les
négociations
un peu au second plan enfin je dirais
justement bord et ça johnson souhaite
être fixé dès le mois de juillet 1 sur
un éventuel compromis vous l'avez dit
les européens sont plutôt pour l'instant
concentrés sur cette crise post que
vides 19 il parle du mois d'octobre
comme véritable moment propice pour le
break site est ce que vous partagez cet
avis par le volet c'est que on sait pas
du tout ce qui va émerger de ces six
semaines va vite et vous même de
négociation ce qui change c'est que
jusque là c'était des zooms avec des
centaines de conseillers qui étaient là
entre les deux parties là pour la
première fois depuis hier des fastes et
michel barnier des deux principaux
protagonistes voix en tête-à-tête donc
connaissait bruxelles comme moi c'est
plutôt au cours de dîners en ville ou de
petite blinde dans les coulisses que les
relations humaines se tissent dont
peut-être ça va déclencher quelque chose
mais le problème de fond à mon avis
reste que les britanniques ne savent
toujours pas après quatre ans et demi ce
qu'ils veulent
d'ailleurs si je peux juste
rappeler que dans tous les sondages
d'opinion a complètement viré en
grande-bretagne derniers sondages
c'était que c'était 56 consent des gens
votre est maintenant pour rester dans
l'union européenne la grande bretagne
n'a jamais vraiment dit clairement ce
qu'elle veut de ces négociations
d'accords et peut regarder ces poissons
mais ce qu'on ne dit pas assez c'est que
la grande bretagne va avoir accès pour
ses services financiers pas beaucoup
plus important de l'économie britannique
que la pêche veut toujours avoir accès
au marché européen pour leurs services
financiers donc c'est du donnant donnant
donc pour le moment chacun comme ceux-ci
position je veux garder mes poissons
d'accord mais en même temps comment bien
peu pour attendre le reportage la
plupart de ces poissons britanniques et
les britanniques eux-mêmes pêche qui les
vendent sur le marché européen
donc c'est vraiment du donne justement
peut-être peut-être avec le co vide et
avec tous tes crise qui nous tombe
dessus
ça va focaliser un peu les esprits pour
que des compromis émerger alors on vient
de parler justement de ce problème de la
pêche mais il ya bien évidemment
d'autres points qui restent à la table
des négociations
quels sont justement les autres dossiers
sur lesquels il n'y a pas encore
d'accord
chaque classe s'est pas tellement des
deux surfaces et boutiques de style
comme par exemple droit add britannique
moi je suis
je suis citoyen britannique dans l'union
européenne les gens sont toujours pas
vraiment fixés sont des droits que nous
aurons nous qui vivons dans les pays les
uns des autres
après le brésil mystère c'est plutôt des
problèmes de manière générale sur les
règles du jeu équitables
si la grande bretagne va voir à un doigt
de travail différent va avoir d'autres
règles sont aides apportées par l'état à
leur industrie ça veut dire que les
règles du jeu ne sont pas les mêmes
donc c'est plutôt sur ces questions là
et aussi qu'ils goût qui décide en cas
d'un conflit
c'est un problème majeur parce que si
vous le cil
après le frère excite à la fin de cette
année si un désaccord entre les deux
parties qui doit décider qui a raison
dans ses cdd problème de taille les six
premiers de deux tailles dont on discute
depuis quatre ans et demi espérant que
dans les six semaines à venir que des
solutions sont se dégage sinon c'est de
suspense le plus total merci beaucoup
fall ex taylor d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des questions
européennes